what you're saying to me
is is that
as a layperson
is that in my lifetime
that
machines will have consciousness
oh that i don't know computers i'm one
of the people with depending here you
live dangerously so i don't know how
long you're going to live
so let's let's put
but i believe that consciousness yes
could be engineered in the machine
uh or at least we can have machines that
are human-like
and we believe they have consciousness
can i ask you one last question about it
yes okay
but just one more will they have the
smoothness of skin and will they look
realistic
see i'm one of those people that
believes that visual appearance isn't
the magic
so if you close your if you're blind you
can still have a connection with a
person
people can fall in love with each other
through just letters
so yeah i know you're mocking me with
your entire energy but yes
um yes i believe that part two you're
talking about sex spots is what you're
probably getting okay intimacy
just friends friends but you wanted you
want to feel the smoothness yeah like a
guy like a you know just go what's up
dude and just just just hug and and yeah
like on both cheeks kind of thing i get
what you're saying though right
obviously there's no soul right you know
i mean and i'm just curious to see
you're right i was going with sex bots
but yeah
have you seen whitney uh cummings is
robot yeah i've seen it okay yeah how
did that make you feel
she's a beautiful girl i just don't find
her attractive the robot or whitney i
find the robot way more attractive
yeah if i had the choice robot so you
were turned on by the robot see i was
surprised
by the very thing you're saying which is
the realism of the skit like it was
quite they did a really good job on that
robot oh they did the the life when when
it's animated the life is not quite
there you can tell it's a robot but just
sitting there
still
it has a lot of human like elements the
texture i don't know yeah yeah it's
quite fast they're getting there they're
getting there yeah yeah but the funny
thing about sex robots is most people
that get sex robots
they don't get it for the sex they get
it for like intimacy
like um
not sexual intimacy but like
just somebody being there it's not it's
the
emotional connection not the sexual yeah
i mean i you know i i saw a long time
ago a um
a documentary about real dolls and
people marrying them yeah yeah and
what i was fascinated about is the
cuddling
you know i mean and then watching tv
together
and stuff like that which i find
you know
i've just been able to
find human girlfriends and stuff
so that's really impressive that's one
of the reasons thanks man yeah
you